all right romaine romaine where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
grew up in chicago chicago
chicago west side and tell me about your
family growing up you had mom and dad
yeah i had a mom and dad i grew up in a
house with five sisters you know didn't
have any brothers and
mom alone on welfare and
grew up in the neighborhood where as the
drug dealers and the pimps and
everything was you know was just
everything yeah the west side is right
it's the classic uh
hood right right classic hood that's
what it is
where's dad
what do you mean what where did you have
a dad
well i had a father but i didn't have a
father actually growing up you know
immediately in the house no i grew up in
the house with uh five women and my mama
mm-hmm
how far are you in school
i went to
sixth grade and i went laying around and
got a ged you know down the line
and you got started in the game at what
point
i got actually started in the game when
you say game what do you mean just uh in
the game with women in the game period
pimping huh pimping well i got in the
game i would say in about 1906
76 77 and you're you were old i was
17 years old 17.
you learned it from somebody
what happened did you learn from
somebody well i wouldn't
back well you always learn from somebody
but i wouldn't actually just say
i i had a drive for you know in the
neighborhood i come up in this
you know streets where you had don juan
you had the best
you had
you had god you had you know a bunch of
squeaky you had
burrells you know you had guys in
general you know you just had some guys
you look at we you know no matter how
guys may look at it you know bishop was
like a guy in our neighborhood that you
know you know you you wanted to be like
this bishop would cruise down the street
in his green and gold rolls royce yeah
and everybody would point and chase his
car
it won't be like that right there jack
real talk yeah that would have worked he
was a celebrity
he was the celebrity in the hood oh yeah
he was this d celebrity and you know
like i said a lot of guys might say hey
hey you know i don't know how far they
go with them but when you look at it
right now if you look at it today he
really the platform for a lot of stuff
that's going on you know really with
this player yeah with these players you
can't underestimate the importance of
the bishop
in the game right yes right
and uh
tell me about your first girl oh well my
first girl actually was a um
a friend of mine me and a friend of mine
we had a friend named icy we was you
know we was just call ourself players in
the neighborhood and uh
it was this girl she was a um
shooting mom was like a tom boy
and he had a uh down me i mean he was
ella and i was there he messed around
went to the to one of the fawn homes and
when he got back she was my girl you
know and had a baby bad bad then you
know
you have kids how many kids you have i
got five daughters huh oh happy son
you raise your kids or no
well i did a lot of time you know away
for that i wasn't able to actually you
know
raise my daughter the way i wanted the
daughter but you know a lot of you know
a lot of time have been taken away but i
i have had some time now you know
getting my life back in in order to i
have amended a lot of hands you know
so tell me about your history you used
you did some prison time along the way
yeah i did some prison time i had a life
sentencing life sentence right a life
sentence what was that for
why what was that for
uh uh uh
saying some of the i said some things
that would just say saying some things i
shouldn't have said on the phone
and they've given they gave me a life
sentence right here in california
because something i said over the phone
really right
yeah the laws are harsh now oh they lost
they had three strikes law down here you
know and
it doesn't make no difference you know i
could have had priors all the way back
in the 80s they could use those foreign
prizes and give you a life sentence in
california so you know california is a
stiff place you can't find out shaky way
out here today you know so you came to
california at some point but you came to
california at some point
i came to california right in 1995 yeah
and got something and i got a life
sentence in 1995. oh
you wasted no time oh yeah yeah it was
like that look and how many years did
you actually do i actually did 20 years
20 years
right and you got out and came back to
chicago i came home went right back to
chicago that's right
tell me about how the game has changed
over the years
uh let me just say
i think the game changed me personally
this ain't got nothing to do with nobody
because i really have never let anybody
run my poor web or dictate it you know
all questioned it
but the way i think i think danger
change when i when i when i left the
street we used to look at guys that had
jobs and now you say oh he squat oh they
square him and this woman or him and his
girlfriend and his wife all they square
cause there's a lot of money out here
you know so i consider them to be square
but when i came
home i found out that
a lot of squares was actually beating
the players out
real talk
i was looking at some players and
i you know even though i never put a
counter player out because i know a real
player is rubber coated he can bounce
back at any time
you know but it was square that i
thought was square these people got
million dollar homes
you know what i'm saying i'm saying damn
they really beating the players out
round here now you know it was it it
really has changed because
you know you got a younger generation
right now and they got a way of thinking
that
this the game go like this and you guys
the older generation to thank the gang
go like that but you know it's still the
same game it's like baseball i mean you
you get in the battle box to run over
you hit the ball to go on first base
second base third base and come on
that's baseball that's the way that gang
go you don't get in the game a baseball
and hit the ball to run back in the
stand you see them saying so
some people don't twist it up you might
want to slide on first base you know
somebody's still second base
you know what i'm saying uh
somebody might still play
do you think the qualities
a man needs to do this is something you
you're born with or something you learn
i think actually that
it's something that actually grows into
you
because to me i actually felt that that
at one time and i still feel
a lot of times today that next to
pimpism
is god-ism
it's just a big feeling it's a good
feeling you know you
you can get a whole lot of money over
here
you might get a fit a good feeling from
it but if you get some you might get you
you can you not have to get that much
money over here with this hole and it's
a much better feeling i mean you know
just what it is do what it is and tell
me about the the women that
that you work with is that something
that
not any not any girl can be a whole
right
would i say any girl can be a whole yeah
i would say so i don't think any not not
no it's a
i think anyone can sell [ __ ] yes but i
don't think now one just any anyone can
be a hoe you know cause you got a lot of
women out here right now don't even know
they hold they don't [ __ ] they balls
they don't have sex with the supervisor
for a different spot in jail you know
what i'm saying but then their downward
assistant coach she sold her [ __ ] and
did what she wanted to do with her money
so
no i don't i don't think it like that no
no way
and what is your style
of being pimp i mean some you know some
of the reputation of pimps is that they
use force and intimidation
or even drugs to get the girls to do
what they want other guys are charming
and
seducing well i don't think i think
everybody play a different kind of game
i'll never question nobody pimping and i
know it's a lot of guys out here say the
gang go like this you got another guy
wrote a book and said go like that you
got another guy they go they say it goes
like this
but like i say it's only one way to play
the game you understand me and that's
that you have to get paid
how many girls you have
well you know right now i can't even see
how many girls i have right now
the reason why i can't see how many
girls i have it's because the law might
be watching
it's because the law might be watching i
mean you know i mean i wouldn't want to
say anything you know that would you
know deeply incriminate me right how do
i get you in trouble okay
and what do you think of technology and
how it's played a role in the game now
technology yeah internet all that
well is the track still the way
i
as far as the internet is concerned
my idea of a real chick really getting
some money is on the concrete i mean i
just you know i don't like the internet
chicks in the cypress base chicks you
dig i just
i'd rather see them getting straight on
the concrete
you ever been in love before
of course
with one of your girls
i don't see somebody
have i ever been in love one of my my
girl
of course i have five women who love
every one of them
every one of them was not one i didn't
love
what was your what was your favorite
part of your life
what the favorite part of my life would
have been i would say probably back in
89 90
you know everybody got a point in their
life where they blossomed
you know where things went real good for
them and i would say probably
i i had really beginning to blossom
probably maybe 89 or 90.
money was good
that money was good you know it was a
different kind of thing even though we
still had drugs around you know you
still had
a lot of good instruction and then come
around with the
cyber spray based women's and uh the
chicks with the you know uh uh running
all being renegades and
you know it just got real messed up you
know i think that uh
back then
was a better time where i can go further
back than when it was good but you know
it's just somebody right now
it could be their time
and you know and it just might not be
somebody else's time somebody had a good
time five years ago
somebody might have had a bad time 20
years ago and having a good time today
you know you know it that's why i never
count a player out you know i never
count nobody out
you know i never i i never say uh i
don't speak to this game as levels you
know what i'm saying because
i can say this man is on my level he is
on that level you're not on my level but
how can i say that when this man can
walk into a 7-eleven with the right damn
number and i'm no longer on his level
you know what i'm saying i'm no longer
on this level no more so that's why i
don't use levels you know what i'm
saying because anybody can flip we all
rubber coated we bounce back you did
yeah survival and
it's really just
an
elevated form of street hustling right
uh elevator for him
and what do you mean just it's a lot of
a lot of people in the hood are hustlers
right and this becomes like a
um elevated way of of hustling where
you're driving a beautiful car and
you're dressed nice and you're
surrounded by beautiful women
right okay i would say that i would i
would say that it it's much it's much
more respected than being a drug dealer
perhaps
well i i i i it is because i think that
drug dealers can any drug
dealer actually if he is a true drug
dealer i actually think he could
he can outshine a pill he's gonna tell
you the truth yeah he can make it we're
very well outside of him but
you know when you weigh it all down you
know his problems are bigger than a pimp
you know what i'm saying he may have to
have his child to go to school with
protection or halfway you know he can't
wife can't go to the grocery store you
know what i'm saying you know
his problems is bigger put it right
there but right now nowadays a lot of
these guys is giving these guys the game
the wrong way because
you know they're telling these guys how
good this game can be but they're not
telling about the football numbers that
they can receive behind this game right
now yeah you know you know you know
they're there tell them how you can do
this and tell them how you do that but
they're going to tell them they'll say
hey you know you can get a football
number behind
this stage too you know because it's a
big
there's a lot of big a lot of people are
taking some hell of a fall right now you
know what i'm saying man and these guys
you know they'd be some good hat good
guys good hustler get caught up in the
wrong twist and down goes frazier man
you know real tough like that
how long do you think you'll be doing it
what'd you say now how long do you think
you'll be in the game until you die
i actually think i'll be in the game
probably the rest of my life i just i i
don't think you know my ways have
changed you know i can say i've tried
them but they they don't seem to work
you know what i'm saying they just you
know somehow it's like uh dr jekyll and
mr hyde it's like something just keep
coming back for you you know i can't sit
up with a square alone you know because
it's not me you did what i'm saying i
it's not a square is not me so i mean
you know you know some things just go
together shoes and clothes pimps and
hoes you know some things just go
together and that's the way it is and
there ain't no way you can change it do
you have any regrets in your life any
what
regrets plenty regrets i regret the fact
that uh i i
abandoned uh the game had caused me to
abandon my daughters you know and i
didn't give them the uh
proper attention as a father that i
should have gave in them you know but
like i say life is good now and i'm able
to amend a lot of hands you know from
coming out from a life sentence you know
i want to lead them some
more than than just a death ticket in a
uh
a burial from prison so now i get a
chance to you know i mean a whole lot of
ends with them and i'm cool with my
daughters i mean we should we jab jack
for real you know that's great
and what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
what was the what now the most important
thing you've learned in your life
the most important thing i
learned
in my life
would be
that you just cannot trust anybody
i learned that i learned the hard way i
had somebody looking me in my face and
telling me a thing and i end up getting
a life sentence you just cannot trust
any you know i think trust had to be
built people use that world of saying
have to be
built you have to build it you have to
see it but trust is a big thing
in my life you see what i'm saying man
i'd rather for you to tell me the truth
any day if you got to tell me a damn lie
i'm just done with your ass i mean the
gig is up right there you know as soon
as i found out that life that loud that
light bulb bounced out your ass the gig
is up simple as that ain't i'm not
tolerating with no light cause i'm gonna
tell the truth and i'm too truthful
and even when i was in the game i never
told a chick
to go to work and then i got your back
you understand me how can i help you
back i'm at home you know saying man can
i help you but go to the trooper i'm
down here with the players you know i'm
riding around
i i gave it to him in a row i let him
know right off the bat baby you can jump
in that car this would be the last car
you ever jumped in in your life and you
got to go in there thinking it just like
that i kept it all real you did one
thing that's why it's been real with me
all right romaine thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you i wish you
the best of luck out there you know hey
man i like that be careful
be careful
you